je m'appelle gonda jean-hugues j'ai 46
ans j'habite à petit saint-pierre
avant je travaillais dans une entreprise
où j'ai fait un accident de travail
donc j'ai voulu convertir j'ai hérité
d'un terrain agricole d'un hectare à 59
que je me suis installé dessus malgré
leur handicap oui c'est ce n'était pas
idéal pour la botter le cul à mais j'ai
pu monter des serres et puis faire des
fruits de la passion pour l'exploitation
ce qu'on a fait le choix de utiliser
l'eau de pluie récupération de l'opé
principalement provenant des toitures du
cca pour pouvoir irriguer ses fruits de
la passion et être autonome en eau d'un
modèle de développement durable donc il
a choisi comme ça de ma vie mais celle
déjà cessé c'est ma famille mes enfants
il faut bien que je travaille pour les
nourrir et donc il fallait pas que je
laisse tomber c'est sûr j'ai cru que je
pouvais plus rien faire parce que
j'avais quand même des séquelles
beaucoup mal je fais des efforts au
niveau là de la culture de fruits de la
passion des difficultés c'est surtout le
pic de travail au niveau de la
pollinisation
donc il a adapté quand même c'est son
palissage 27 en hauteur par rapport à
son handicap par rapport à son dos
la coloration l'odeur est aussi le goût